Hello Snips
Master?
The world between worlds, then,
you know, it's not about time travel.
It's really not about time travel at all.
It's just about a place
where everything comes together
and you hear different things
echoing throughout time.
It's not the most desperate because it's
all fluid in that moment, in that place.
It's not this material thing
that's linear.
What have made it is only one day.
Everything is occurring all the time
and Ezra is more
in tune with the things that are directly
related to him.
Like when he was on Malick
or in Star Soldier.
Like when he saw Kanan die.
These things reverberate to him
and he understands them,
or the other voices seem to understand
he's not those people.
Master Yoda,
Obi-Wan.
They're just like the wind moving.
And he recognizes
some, like Obi-Wan and Yoda.
But he doesn't understand
the context of anything that's going on.
I don't know how real it actually is.
I don't want to define that for people
anyway.
But it's not this place of gateways
and doorways
that you just go in and out of now
as you can pull this out into that world.
But remember, she's smart enough
to know that she can't leave that world
through his door.
She'll be destroying the natural balance
and order of things.
She has to go back from where she came.
It's the same with Kanan.
I can reach you, Ezra.
Kanan gave his life so that you could live
when you understand that
if he pulls him out of that world, he.
He's got to put them back in a world
where everybody is dead.
And then you know that. Wait.
As you couldn't
have been in that world then.
And so everything will break and will
cause chaos and will cause destruction.
So it's not this
system of doorways
like you're on an elevator getting off
on different floors in different times.
It's more like what the wolf tells Ezra.
It's more about knowledge,
knowledge
that you can use for your benefit
of good or knowledge
that will lead to destruction.
That's what it's about.
But it's not my intention
that it be this ability to walk
through into somebody else's world.
We have to keep being dedicated
to being original and creative.
And sometimes we take chances
and sometimes we do
weird things like create bandhu or,
you know, mysterious wolves.
And but I think as long as you work off
the principles of the forest
that George set up,
that it doesn't change it
and you don't erode
what makes Star Wars special.
Welcome back, everyone, it's Charlie
Dave Filoni did a much bigger explainer
on how the world between worlds works
and how everyone is able
to see each other.
Everyone still alive.
Well, this is happening
even though they're coming
from different points in their timeline.
So I'll explain how.
And again, Scott Walker returns how
he appears in this place, even though he's
the Clone Wars age and again in a soldier
fell off the cliff and almost died
almost, but was also pulled into the world
between worlds.
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'm doing videos for all the episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
We're also doing a giveaway for Disney
plus memberships.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and just post all your Ahsoka
and and Skywalker theories on the video.
Dave Filoni here uses all the world
between worlds, stuff that he's introduced
so far between Star Wars
rebels now in a soldier in live action
to explain what the world between worlds
actually is, how it exists
and what happens when you're inside of it.
There aren't necessarily any rules
about how you use it like it just exists,
and people can use it
however they want to.
But he also explained
some of the consequences of what they do
when they're inside here.
the world between Worlds
is kind of like another layer of reality
that's connected to every moment in time
and space all at the same time.
I made the joke in an earlier video.
Everything everywhere, all at once.
you can also make the Harry Potter
reference to like the pathways
that Anna-Kat
and her soccer are walking on right now
are kind of like platform nine
and three quarters in the World
Between Worlds is kind of like a train
depot with railways connecting
to all moments
everywhere in time and space.
Dave Filoni also explains it's
not meant to be just as simple as that.
Like it's not just a bunch of gateways
you can enter and exit
at different moments in the timeline,
in different places in the universe.
Those gateways do exist here.
Like you can do that.
but there's a couple of important reasons
why you should not do that.
Typically, the ones that Ezrin
also can see when they're walking around
in the world between worlds then
in a Soldier Episode five in Live action
that also can and again,
we'll see as they continue to walk around
and talk with each other will be portals
to other time periods that are specific
to the people that are witnessing them.
places and times
that were meaningful to them.
But not always.
For example, like when Ezra enters,
he hears voices from Leia, from Obi-Wan
Kenobi,
from different parts of the timeline,
from the different Star Wars movies,
because he has an experience.
Those, as are coming from the future,
he has no idea who those people are like.
He doesn't know who Obi-Wan Kenobi is yet,
and he doesn't know who Princess
Leia is yet.
that will also probably happen
to Aniket and Ahsoka in this place too.
And you have to remember that this is
an action coming from the clone Wars.
so a lot of the stuff that they see
will probably be from his future
that he will not have experienced yet.
that's part of the reason
why they played that Darth Vader music
at the end of the episode.
one of the other examples that Dave
Filoni used was Emperor Palpatine
also trying to enter the world
between worlds back in one of his six
temples around that same time period.
Like this was meant to be Palpatine
from that same era during the Star Wars
Rebel series.
it's not like the world between Worlds
just exists in this moment, just for an
akin in a soldier or back during Star Wars
Rebels for Ahsoka and Ezra Bridger
like you have people from all across
time and space everywhere in the timeline
trying to enter and exit this place
simultaneously.
they just didn't show all of them
on screen when this was happening?
So theoretically,
when Ahsoka is seeing Anneke and Skywalker
here in this moment
on the Ahsoka series later in her timeline,
while this is happening,
like in the exact same time period,
Ezra and Ahsoka are walking around
a different part of the world
between worlds
having their experience too.
Because everything here
happens at the same time.
You'd have this other Ahsoka
and Aniket walking around
a different part of the world
between worlds in the same moment.
there's a whole bunch of Ahsoka,
a whole bunch of anarchy
and a whole bunch of everybody else
just walking around the world
between worlds all at the same time.
Dave Filoni then explains
why Ahsoka can't just pull in a Kid
Skywalker from the past the Clone Wars
era into her present day, thus saving him
theoretically from ever
becoming Darth Vader just as earlier
before a new hope when she was in the War
Between Worlds with Ezra,
he couldn't save Kanan from dying
by yanking him before he died.
I can stop Cain from dying.
You can't save your master.
And I can't save my.
I made the reference in an earlier video
about how
this is
like the Last Temptation of Ahsoka.
She'll be tempted to save Anakin
Skywalker, even though she probably won't.
Because if Ahsoka were to try and save
and again, Skywalker baby erasing
everything those people ever did
or influenced after these moments.
The butterfly effect would happen,
changes would ripple out.
It would just make things worse.
And worse and worse.
Theoretically, in those timelines.
They don't get too deep into the weeds.
On how time travel works in the Star Wars
universe during this trailer video here.
and it's a little bit like the way time
travel works on the Loki series,
if you were able to time travel
into the past,
you could change something, but
you wouldn't be changing your own past.
You just be creating a branch timeline.
so you wouldn't be changing
your own future, you just be creating
a totally new timeline
with a totally different future.
So if Ahsoka were to try and save Anakin
by pulling him into her present day,
she would be changing her own past
to just be creating a new timeline
where he never became Darth Vader
and just didn't exist in that timeline
for about 30 plus years because he'd just
be jumping forward into present day.
during his past year where he came from.
PADMÉ wasn't pregnant with Luke and Leia
yet, so they would have never been born.
the rebellion probably never
would have defeated the Empire.
Darth
Vader would never have killed the emperor.
The rebels might never have destroyed
the first star
because Luke Skywalker never existed
to destroy the first Death Star.
then things probably just continue
to get worse in that particular
new branch timeline that Ahsoka created
where Anakin did not exist.
but even still, Ahsoka sees Anakin here.
He's alive. He's not a force ghost.
She understands how the war between worlds
works fundamentally.
She's been here before, like, Oh,
I remember this place.
so she knows this really him
that she's talking to here.
He's not quite sure how she wound up
in here, how Ian Akin wound up in here.
But she gets
what's happening in this moment.
She gets a chance to see him again
as he was before everything went to shit.
Glory days in a can. Skywalker.
according to reports, a lot of episode
five will be spent with a spoken Anakin
doing something similar to what a spoken
Ezra did when they were in the world
between worlds.
But with the roles flipped,
like they'll look
through different portals
to different moments.
In a soldier's past
They're supposed to be a Clone Wars
flashback with Anakin in his Clone Wars
armor in a younger.
So I don't know who's playing
that younger version of Ahsoka
There might also be a flashback
to Ahsoka versus Darth Vader in their fight
in the Sith Temple during twilight
of The Apprentice in Star Wars Rebels,
which is also where we get to the idea
that this Anakin Skywalker will witness
some of his future because those events
will not have happened
for this Anakin yet.
this is where Dave Filoni explains the
real value of the world between worlds.
It's all about knowledge
of the past in the future,
and how you use that knowledge.
think about how this would affect both.
So again and again and again,
we'll be able to see his future,
how he falls the Dark side Order 66,
how he becomes Darth Vader.
But on the good side of that,
he might be able to see the birth of Luke.
And maybe if we're lucky,
he'll also get to see his redemption
on the Second Death Star when he saves
Luke Skywalker by killing the Emperor.
it if he sees his future
or any parts of his future,
think about how
that would completely recontextualize
all the Star Wars movies
and all the stuff that takes place
after the Clone Wars, particularly
the events of the original trilogy.
he'd be living through all these years
after Revenge of the Sith, ultimately
knowing that he'd be destined
to kill the Emperor,
that Luke and lay his children were alive
out in the galaxy somewhere.
So think about how that would affect him.
they kind of danced around this problem
of pre knowledge during the Obi-Wan
Kenobi series,
like they never had Darth Vader in Young
Leia be that close to each other in scenes
enough for him to censor
through the force.
That's why, if you probably noticed,
Darth Vader was never at the Fortress
inquisitors when Leia was there.
otherwise he would have sensed
who she was with the force
and would have completely changed
the timeline.
He would have turned her
into another inquisitor.
they actually covered that storyline
during a Star Wars.
What if comic book back when Dark Horse
was still doing the Star Wars comics
la la.
Briefly turns to the dark side,
winds up having to fight Luke Skywalker
on the Death Star instead of Luke
Skywalker facing Darth Vader.
maybe someday they'll do a
What If Star Wars series.
That would be pretty cool.
Let me know in the comments.
Do you think that?
And then we'll see some moments
from his future in the War between Worlds.
And how do you think that
he'll react to Darth Vader?
the other big idea Dave Filoni gets into
is what's going to happen after.
So can and again are done talking
to each other, reminiscing on old times
and seeing a bunch of flashbacks
from their shared history.
during the Star Wars Rebels episode,
Ahsoka realized she couldn't just jump
through Ezra's portal into his present day
because she'd be creating
out of the branch timeline.
She had to find a way to go back
through the portal that he pulled her from
to the Sith Temple, which was in
the middle of collapsing, by the way.
But now that she knows what's
going to happen, she has an escape plan.
She's able to survive, as is Darth
Vader, to continue into the future
where you see her in present day.
so likely what'll happen at the end of a
so can and again Skywalker's
adventure in episode
five in the World between Worlds
is that Anakin
will realize that he has to go back
through his portal to the Clone Wars
era that he came from in Ahsoka
We'll have to go back through her portal
to the Cetus plane
where she just left from.
right now, without more evidence
I think that Mirai in the is gods
pulled both of them into the world
between worlds
because the sukkah
was falling off the cliff,
she would have had to have been pulled in
by someone in Mirai
shows up all the time.
When Ahsoka shows up So Mirai might show up
somewhere during episode five as well.
There was an owl during the Mandalorian
season two when Ahsoka Cameoed
So let me know if you think that Mirai
will also be part of the reason
why both she and Aniket
wound up in the world between worlds.
the real reason why the mortis gods
probably orchestrated this event
that we're seeing happen here
is that Ahsoka can see the danger
that Tron's return will pose.
Like she'll learn a little bit
about their own future timeline with Ron's
return in the upcoming heir to the Empire
movie should learn
a little bit more about this grand plan
that balance school has for the galaxy
that it's as you'll be able
to use that knowledge to help them fight.
Thrawn
even though we know that he's coming back
and there will be a giant movie
where they have their Star Wars,
like ultimately
some of this stuff will play out
no matter what
in and again will probably just return
to his time period in the Clone Wars
and won't necessarily change anything
using advanced knowledge of the future.
But his internal motivation
will fundamentally change
so that when you're seeing him later
in the timeline,
his reasons for doing things will change.
suppose all your theories in the comments
blow my full episode by video post
next week.
After they release it, click here
for that already the link
as soon as I posted and click here
for all my Ahsoka episode videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!